[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanut
peanuts famed Comedy Club Caroline's on
Broadway is closing its doors after 30
years Comedy Club Caroline's on Broadway
says it's leaving its Times Square
location
all right
kind of a smaller version of the last
guy
what are we doing oh just gonna murder
you
what was like this God shows up right
before he does he goes hey what are you
doing
this is in the Bible I swear to God
that's my time
upstairs it would be different if I was
getting robbed by big people it was a
great spot for us because we got to open
for big names you know it's like Jim
Jeffries or David tell or Dr Stanhope
today's Tuesday December 13th and sadly
one of the Premier comedy clubs in all
of the world Caroline's in New York City
has officially announced that after 30
wonderful years at our location in Times
Square we have decided not to renew our
lease our final shows here will begin on
December 31st Caroline's closing down is
a huge deal to comedians all over the
place but especially to all the New York
City Comics who had been performing
there for years and years and years now
unfortunately I never have had the
chance to go to the original Caroline's
room so I reached out to a comedian that
knows the club well to share some of his
experiences and insights with the
legendary venue now join the show from
New York City and the first guest to
ever be on the joke World comedy update
Mark Norman mark thank you for being
here today hey thank you sir good to be
here comedy so for unfortunately
Caroline's is closing down as we heard
and uh just for those of us who have
never had a chance to visit the club
what made it so special to you and all
these other comedians
wow it's funny to say I was there last
night did a show uh it's sad it's like a
New York staple it's had like four
locations fun fact started as a cabaret
Club in Chelsea and they did comedy on
Monday and then comedy was so successful
they said we'll do it Monday and Tuesday
and then they just said [ __ ] it we're
going all comedy so
it's a it's like an open microwave just
start at the bottom and then it became
the premiere Comedy Room and uh now
rents are too high and
thing the economies of the theater so
that's it damn so from your perspective
as a comedy fan your whole life growing
up in New Orleans did you have any
recollection of this club have you ever
heard of it before moving to New York
I'd heard of it you know there was a
show called evening at The Improv and I
believe that film to Caroline's back in
the day uh and then moving in New York
they were one of the first clubs to work
young Comics because they did a uh a
thing called New York's funniest and
anybody could audition you only got a
minute and uh I won that in like 2012.
but uh yeah
it was a great spot for you and they fed
you you got free drinks they had a
Christmas party did a New Year's show so
it was like a cool room and it was a
great spot for us because we got to open
for big names you know it's like Jim
Jefferies or Dave Attell or Doug
Stanhope or Brian Regan whoever was
coming to town do you remember the first
time you ever got to perform on that
main stage with a legendary backdrop
that we see so much in Clips or specials
boy I mean I was there so much I don't
really remember the first time I'm sure
it was a contest of sorts you know and
I'm sure I bombed horribly but uh you
keep going back yeah well one last
question for you here Mark do you have
any favorite memories or funny stories
from your time working that stage
wow well let's see
a member of New Year's Eve one night it
was me Dan Soder Michelle wolf Gary
veter Sam Muriel Joe it was like a great
group and Michelle wolf got so drunk she
blacked out and I think fell asleep in
the Green Room that was fun uh I
remember watching uh I saw Bill Burr
there and he did that special I can't
remember what the name of it maybe Let
It Go but it was sold out it was before
he was huge and he sold it out and me
and Nate bargatzi want to watch and it
was Unreal he did the whole bit about uh
Arnold Schwarzenegger he's like this
guy's been killing he married to Kennedy
he was Mr Universe then he became the
governor of a state he can't even
pronounce
uh I can't remember the special yeah but
I got to see it I got to see his Rise
um I saw Paul Mooney there I saw Doug
Stanhope there and he saw David tell in
the back and he goes Dave what are you
doing here and David teller goes well I
heard a white voice coming out of
Caroline so I had to see who it was they
were they were booking a lot of black
accidents yeah so uh you know Dave's the
funniest guy on the planet so yeah so
many great memories I hooked up with a
waitress there years ago uh good times
good times love it sounds like a lot of
your best times were just as a fan of
Comedy getting to see just the legends
that that were performing there and then
you are now one of those legends that
was performing there so that's that's
pretty crazy but Mark thank you so much
for coming on the show today and I want
to let you know I have my bottle of
Bodega cat whiskey here it came in the
mail two days ago and I'm looking
forward I'm gonna do a video review
where I drink the whole bottle and then
talk about my experience so we'll see
how that goes God love you you're a man
tension if I was gay I'd blow you same
here thank you again Mark and uh we'll
hopefully talk soon
thank you praise Allah we also reached
out to a few up and coming New York City
comedians who just got the chance to
perform at Caroline's right before they
announced her closing that longer video
is going to come out on our second
Channel clip World later this week
featuring comedians Kyle Gillis Nick
viegas Denison sleeper and more your
mom's house life a very cool Christmas
took place last Friday with Tom Segura
Christina P Bobby Lee and Josh Potter
all getting together to celebrate the
holiday season and true ymh fashion
Merry Christmas welcome
been planning it for months and it's
finally happened
the expectations going into this event
Friday were through the roof especially
with Bobby Lee on the roster for this
live show but I gotta say personally it
was a little more tame than I expected
it to be even the heavy segment which in
previous ymh lives I've had to just
close my laptop and not even finish the
show this one was a little more
reasonable I think than past episodes or
maybe I've just been watching too much
your mom's house and I'm numb to it all
like Tom and Christina if it gets worse
I'm Gonna Leave
hahaha
nobody's alive from that compilation
that's not to say it wasn't a fun time
and a hilarious show the sketches that
they prepared beforehand were amazing
the banter between Bobby and Tom and
Christina was very funny it's just that
sometimes it felt like almost a normal
podcast episode that you could watch on
YouTube overall it was definitely worth
the ten dollars and if you tuned into
the Y Mage life please comment your
favorite part of the show for me I think
the funniest part was the Christina P
unsolicited lipstick ad that was
hilarious I don't know if Tom paid that
girl to do that or if it was actually
unsolicited but if you watch it you know
what I'm talking about I think that was
the funniest part or them bullying the
guy the newsman from Erie PA to the
point where they checked in later at the
show and he turned his Instagram private
because of how many fans were watching
and hearing Tom say go blow up this
guy's mentions and by the end of the
live show he was Private those are
probably my two favorite moments let me
know yours in the comments
[Music]
Neil Brandon started a brand new podcast
called the blocks podcast episode number
one came out four days ago with the
first guest being David Letterman I'm
tempted to call Bert
I'm gonna call Bert because he'll he
will absolutely uh love this that you
know who he is and and and are
questioning what are the chances that
you're actually going to get him on the
phone uh well I think pretty good let's
see what this could this is like a radio
contest
hey do you want to leave a message for
him yeah
you may hang up or press one for more
options
hi Bert it's Neil Brennan and Dave
Letterman and we're talking about you
and the fact you don't wear a shirt uh
and I was delighted and pleased to know
two things one that you think without
the shirt or without without the shirt
people wouldn't like you and also last
year on the road you made 25 million so
all my best and congratulations great
got that knocked out blocks is also the
name of his latest special on Netflix so
he's using some of the momentum from his
special just launch a new podcast which
I think is a great move for Neil a lot
of people would say the podcast Market
is oversaturated at this point but he
has such a unique perspective and an
interesting career mix that with his
ability to get big celebrity guests like
David Letterman and I don't think this
podcast is ever going to get lost in the
shuffle you can check out episode one of
blocks featuring David Letterman on Neil
Brown's YouTube channel right now or no
after this finish this video retention
rate guest spots from last week your
mom's house talked with Phil Hanley two
bears one cave was Burt and Tom Tom and
Bert Giannis Papas was on taking your
shoes off with Rick Glassman yonks was
also on Whiskey Ginger so big week for
Giannis fans kill Tony last night was
with Kurt Metzger the ru garbage boys
were on stavy's world and liver King was
the guest on flagrant you should eat the
donut what is it what is the 10. yo
we're hanging with the boys you got
another one right here what is the 10th
ancestral tennis exactly
yeah
one bite come on never again we're gonna
have fun with the boys what's the word
to the liver Queen I promise he takes
one bite he's not gonna you know lose
the family or anything like that it's
just a little bit of fun
you know what let's hang on to this for
a minute let's hang on let's hang on to
this take a bite of that put it on your
pecker right there I guarantee I
guarantee I'll eat the rest of it
that's exactly what I want to do with
guys around the [ __ ] couch what the
[ __ ] always do back in the day you don't
think the ancestors were whacking off
I'm saying yeah you know what I I don't
know what do you think
this past weekend and Thea Von talked
with a retired police officer The Joe
Rogan Experience was a new protect our
Parks the boys were all on shrooms
that's a hilarious episode definitely
recommend we might be drunk talking with
Bobby Kelly and Liz ferrarcti the
Honeydew had on Ari shaffir are you
garbage talked with Fahim Anwar and
tigerbelly had on Neil Brennan also Mark
Norman was on the comedy news update
don't forget about that that's [ __ ]
insane what else do you need to see to
subscribe as far as new comedy specials
go there's a few that have come out
recently that are worth the watch
starting off with Aaron Berg stands down
that's on YouTube right now and it's a
full hour also YouTube related Comedy
Central started to pull some of their
old specials that they filmed years
before and re-upload them fresh onto
YouTube there's a brand new Sam Morrell
called positive influence on comedy
Central's page right now that's a full
hour and it's not new but it is new to
YouTube also Micron and thick worm is on
YouTube and one last special Doug by
Matt brockner it's a full hour that
sounds like it has a ton of potential to
be very funny just based on the way he
talked about it with Ryan sickler on the
Honeydew that does it for this week's
joke World comedy update as always thank
you so much for watching this video and
we'll be back again next Monday with
some more comedy news these usually come
out every single Monday but this week we
had the rare chance to interview Mark
Norman for the comedy news I feel like
that's an excuse that's passable for
getting it out a day late but what do
you guys think I mean if you've been
supporting this channel since day one is
that not the most exciting moment like
we just had Mark Norman live on the
comedy news update giving his two cents
on the story that we're talking about
it's just a cool opportunity and I want
to thank all of you guys for making it
possible for subscribing and liking and
showing him that this is a show worth
coming on which I definitely think it is
and I think that you guys can agree to
but yeah today was really cool and it's
all because of you guys so this is a
serious ending now um just thanks man we
got Mark Norman on the comedy news and
it's just going up from here dude
hopefully this starts a trend of actual
interviews on the topics of what we're
talking about with the comedians that it
affects instead of me just inferring
what they're probably thinking
I don't know this could be another step
forward for joke world legitimizing the
brand going forward thank you to Mark
norm and thank you to all the
subscribers who made it possible for
Mark Norman to even want to come on this
show and I'll see you guys all again
next Monday sorry for this gay ending
thank you foreign
[Music]